hi I'm Erik Bosse and aventures endgame
is the title of the next Avengers movie
with a new trailer showing us the Bleak
aftermath of infinity war hey kids this
is what your toys look like when you
give half of them away to charity our
friends so long partner
this at the conclusion is coming April
26 and sure this trailer doesn't seem to
have a whole lot of details but you know
that doesn't stop us
Izu enhance on everything well you got
to do is get real close to the screen
and then like cross your eyes and then
never sleep let's go through this frame
by frame and find all the goodies that
you might have overlooked spoiler
warning in case any of those goodies
that I noticed we're not meant to be
noticed and before we begin thank you to
our sponsor Wix Wix allows you to build
your own professional website we are
actually using it to build a new new
rockstars website for you guys but more
on that later let's get started
[Music]
staying on
Haman's putz if you find this recording
don't feel better about this part of the
journey use the end ok this trailer
opens with tony stark recording this
depressing Hawaii message for Pepper
Potts he's stranded on the guardianship
now this ship is actually called the
Benatar by the way it's not the Milano
the Milano crashed and the first
Guardians the Benatar was the ship that
the Guardians used to get to Titan and
presumably it still works
so it looks like Tony and nebula used
that to try to return to Earth now Tony
using his Iron Man helmet to record this
farewell to Pepper Potts feels kind of
like a parallel to that moment in the
trailer for Iron Man 2 remember when
pepper kissed the helmet okay give me a
smooch for good luck I might not make it
back this isn't exactly the same Iron
Man helmet but you get the idea right
like here again Tony might not make it
back and he's using this fetched
good-luck charm
to say this little prayer but I gotta
say what is it about lonely spaceman
talking to scar and helmets honestly at
first I thought Tony had kind of lost
his mind and started calling this helmet
mrs. Potts you know it's kind of like
when Homer recreated Mars out of a bush
kiss your helmet wife Tony kisser look
closely at this shot of the Benatar
those definitely look like the wings of
a bird right the way it crosses over
that star it's so cinematic and Purdy to
me it's almost like what you would see
if you were dying in the desert with
vultures or buzzards flying across the
Sun over you waiting for you to finally
croak I've never been in this situation
myself but you can relate either way
this imagery is just so very bleak here
on so many levels let's move on just for
the record being adrift in space with
zero promise of rescue is more fun than
it sounds food and water went out four
days ago
oxygen ran out tomorrow morning man
ok Starck explains the dilemma saying
that he has been without food or water
for four days which is actually exactly
when your body would start to die from
dehydration in real life now we can also
assume that this means the movie will
not begin with a 10-year time jump as we
initially suspected it might though I
suppose it's possible that Tony could be
in a different point of the timeline
from the other characters actually have
some more timeline related thoughts
later
Starck believes that he has zero promise
of rescue but obviously that's not how
it's gonna end for him right so who
could save him now there's always
Captain Marvel who we just learned can
fly through space and kick all kinds of
ass though I guess we have no idea where
she is in 2018 or how she would know
where Stark is or even who he is of
course the work cut out his new fancy
weapons Stormbreaker has the power of
the Bifrost which allows him to teleport
anywhere though again it might be kind
of hard for him to find the benatar if
it's adrift in space
they're also characters like Krag Lin
from the Guardians movies he's
definitely more familiar with the
benatar ship as well as Valkyrie Korg
and the other as Guardians who escaped
from that attack at the beginning of
infinity war but one interesting
possibility could have just been told to
us by Tony Stark himself appear once we
close the record being adrift in space
with zero promise of rescue is more fun
that sounds rescue is actually the name
Pepper Potts goes by when she wears her
own Iron Man armor during the run in the
comics for a brief period when Tony goes
underground we have actually seen some
set photos of Gwyneth Paltrow in armor
perhaps confirming this may be Pepper's
rescue armor and Tony's nanotech armor
have like some kind of GPS find my
friend locator function mosey on to the
next clip when I drift off I will dream
bear you toys you
okay Tony leaves pepper with his sweet
goodbye and turns off the helmet
probably just a battery power look
closely at that eyepiece I'm pretty sure
that that is the mystery extreme closeup
image at the Russo brothers tweeted out
a few months back iron man's eye so
while I could see this whole scene as
not being in the final cut of the movie
like maybe it's just an emotional scene
that the Russos shot for this trailer I
do think that the farewell message
projected from this eyepiece will play
an important role in in game of end
games also notice how Tony moves his
thumb over the eye seemingly caressing
it kiss her or maybe he's like wiping
away it tear like peppers tear or maybe
caps tears or mites here let's move on
and hosted exactly what he said he was
gonna do okay here we check in with
Thanos that maddest of titans in his
agrarian retirement this farm that we
saw him resting on in the final image of
infinity war we now know is actually a
planet that the directors referred to as
Titan two kind of Santa's dream version
of what he wanted his home planet Titan
to be he has hung up his armor to make
this kind of scarecrow actually if he
looked closely and if anymore you could
actually see this in the corner of that
last shot and it's a reference to how
Thanos does this in the Infinity
Gauntlet Comics when he kind of retires
from the war and decides to be a farmer
now we only see Thanos in this one shot
here his fingers are grazing the plant
life of his farm he might recognize the
framing of this kind of shot from a
similar memorable image and movie
Gladiator
that's what Maximus returns home from
his war to his farm you can see Fanus is
kind of in a similar position right he's
a warrior come home but the way Maximus
was Thanos is left with ashes of his
family it's hard to tell but it kind of
looks like Thanos is wearing the
gauntlet here almost like the charred
melted thing has been fused to his arm
like it's no longer much of a deadly
weapon that he wields but really a scar
that he has to bear on his body next
clip he wiped out 50% of all living
creatures
next we see this shot of the Avengers
facility in upstate New York now
comparing this to the wide shots of the
facility in past films it looks like the
place says fallen into a bit of
disrepair right like the grass looks a
bit overgrown the building facade it's
got a little grimy again we don't know
exactly how long it's been since the
snap but this is one of the few shots in
the trailer that shows us the outside
world impact after the snap so you know
Porte went out for Tony Stark's
groundskeepers and I guess for caps of
beer at our snap victim Bruce Banner
reviews the faces of missing friends and
this reminds me a lot of that one panel
in the Infinity Gauntlet comic with cap
mourns a video screen filled with the
fallen heroes after Thanos to snap
though I would definitely miss the Peter
Parker a lot more than some of those
weirdos but look closely at that screen
the red letters there say missing so
maybe they have a separate category for
people they know have faded away and
then this category for people that they
aren't sure about and before that image
on the far right switches to Peter
Parker you can see Cherie black
panther's sister so Scott Lang we know
is missing the quantum realm or a man
later and Peter Parker would probably be
seen as missing because I don't think
anyone actually saw him sneaking aboard
Eboni mod ship but sure he's a more
interesting story the last time we saw
her she was lying on the floor after
Corvus glaive struck her but she
definitely didn't seem dead she would
gotten a much bigger moment if she
really died so why would Shuri be
missing has Wakanda as a nation receded
from the world stage once more
making whereabouts of all their citizens
kind of a mystery did Shuri go
underground just to [ __ ] her brother or
does she go underground to work on some
new secret weapon to come back and
strike Thanos I just loved Bruce's
reaction here considering just a second
ago he found out that spider-man and
ant-man existed at all who's Scott
ant-man there's an ant-man and a
spider-man I'm sorry bro you'll never
meet them moving on we lost all of us
lost friends to us family
you lost a part of ourselves
okay after another shot of the bacons
Avengers HQ we see Thor feel mean and
grief note that he still has that eye
implant that rocket gave him an infinity
war and then we're back again on the
benatar where we see that stark isn't
actually alone nebula left with him on
Titan at the end of infinity war
comforts him resting her hand on his
shoulder I guess their stages of grief
have finally moved on from anger to
depression then we get one of the
biggest reveals of this trailer Hawkeye
he appears to be in Japan here he's got
gauntlets he's got a katana this seems
to be the Ronin incarnation of his
character from the comics Ronin is a
master samurai a lone warrior Hawkeye
takes on this character at some point he
bites a Yakuza he does a bunch of cool
stuff but notice what caps voiceover
says the moment before we see Clint duis
family well this could be hinting at the
reason Clint has run off to this dark
path in Japan
perhaps he lost his entire family in the
dusting like Hawkeye does lose his
family in the Ultimate Comics it kind of
sends him on a very very dark storyline
now I don't mean to wish for all four of
Hawkeye's family members to disappear
but I'll just say this in the HBO series
the leftovers which deals with a rapture
style event the coolest character is a
woman whose entire family disappears and
fun fact she's actually the same actress
who plays Proxima midnight let's move on
to the next clip this is the fight of
our lives this is good work Steve I know
it is cuz I don't know what I'm gonna do
if it doesn't okay in this segment we
see cap in that we've got back and what
looks like the Winter Soldier arrow suit
and we see that he's holding his old
compass now this was the one given to
him by Peggy Carter in the first Captain
America movie the one that he had with
him when his plane went down
now this compass of course is a symbol
for caps unwavering moral character
always pointed in the right noble
direction but notice how this compass is
showing that he's facing north east
that's actually around the same heading
that we saw in the old Quin jet cockpit
in the recent Captain Marvel trailer
that was twenty point six degrees which
is really more around north-northeast
now this could just be a coincidence or
maybe this captain is following in the
footsteps of another ageless captain
taken out of her time on a mission that
took her northeast maybe on a compass
setting there was certain coordinate in
the polar icecaps
where a famous caps plane went down look
I'm not sure if cap and Natalie's
mission here the mission that has to
work
would require a turn to his crash site
in the ice or if it has any connection
to Captain Marvel let me know what you
think in the comments below let's move
on to the title reveal
[Music]
ah-so avengers endgame it is the title
of this movie beam endgame has several
implications first if you watch her
videos you probably know it as the
phrase spoken by dr. strange to Tony
Stark right after strange surrender the
time stone to Thanos
also endgame was the phrase mentioned by
Tony Stark and age of Ultron that up
there that's a cheating game and a fun
fact early last summer endgame was
accidentally leaked as the title of the
movie by cinematographer on his online
resume but it was quickly and quietly
changed around this time the Russo
brothers shot down in game as a title
but you know I guess they technically
weren't line if you consider in-game as
one word not to hmm but what does
in-game mean well it's a chest term
meaning that final phase of the game in
which both sides start making strategic
sacrifices of valuable pieces that they
really want but they do it so that they
can eventually corner their opponents
King to checkmate
they might have to sacrifice their queen
or a bishop or a knight or a time stone
dr. strange looked forward in time at 14
million 605 different timelines and
outcomes and this one was the end game
that he foresaw but I know that's still
not that specific right I've made a
couple videos on what exactly dr.
Strange's plan could be and I'll likely
make several more now but for now let's
look at this imagery from ashes and
broken pieces one solid Avengers a
assembles you could look at this as the
reverse motion of when someone dusts
away as if someone is using the time
stone to reverse the Avengers fading
away into dust but note that the logo
still appears ashy and scarred it's not
fully whole again to me this kind of
signals that the effects of Thanos to
snap can be remedied but not completely
undone like there's always gonna be scar
tissue also notice this big ring that
goes around it it's ghostly it's
spinning remember in the promo imagery
for infinity war there was also a big
ring which later looked a lot like those
forges of 'native lire that Thor used to
create Stormbreaker the god killer
weapon so does this ring represent a god
killer weapon of a different kind maybe
a wormhole or a portal finally there's
the way that the word Avengers
transitions from being translucent to a
more solid state is there any parallel
here with the phase shifting of the
quantum realm
seen with characters like ghosts from
ant-man the wasp who transitioned in and
out of a translucent phase look I know
it sounds like I'm
with this imagery here but you know what
the quantum realm has been confirmed as
important to this movie's plot as seen
in this final clip hi this is Scott Lang
we met a few years ago at the airport
it's just an old message that's me can
you buzz me in okay so somehow Scott
Lang survived and escaped to being stuck
in the quantum realm where we last saw
him in the post-credits scene of ant-man
the wasp note that he has his ex-con
security van which actually contained
the quantum tunnel device so my
immediate question was why does cap
think this is an old message is he just
like an old grandpa yelling at a face
time is this the voice small but it
turns out egg on my ageist face in the
upper left corner of this video message
you can definitely see the word archive
and if you look even closer next to it
and kind of squint your eyes some are
saying there's a year there 1983 I know
it's kind of hard to see cap and black
widows bewilderment here isn't at seeing
a missing hero show up finally it's that
this isn't the front door of the
facility at this moment this is a old
archive video and somehow Scott is
showing up in it the way Nicolas Cage
shows up in old Civil War photos so we
have explored the quantum realm in lots
of videos go watch all of them please
but one detail we learned from the
recent post-credit scene is that it
contains time vortexes don't get sucked
into a time vortex we won't be able to
save you so has Scott done exactly that
gotten all stuck into a time vortex in
the quantum realm and then somehow spit
back out in the early 80s like I suppose
he would have tried to go to Avengers HQ
and I suppose Scott could be dense
enough to not realize America was 35
years earlier and maybe just assume the
Avengers would open the door now years
before Tony Stark converted this
facility into Avengers HQ this was an
old stark building according to Hank Pym
in the first ant-man when he sent Scott
to break into it and steal that device
it's currently collecting dust see one
of Howard Starks old storage facilities
in upstate new
warehouse it's not you son-of-a-bitch
so maybe now Scott has made kind of a
reverse mistake in some earlier time in
the old security cameras recorded him
trying to find them but no one was there
to answer and it just got stored in the
archives for years and years and years
until present-day Captain America and
Natalie realized that time travel
through the time vortex is of the
quantum realm is the way they can defeat
Thanos yep this could just be all the
Avengers crammed into Scott Lang's
time-traveling Mystery Machine
kinda like scooby-doo and Shaggy they'll
rip off that gauntlet like a ghost sheet
off the old man Panos no no would have
gotten away with it too if it weren't
for that time meddling ant-man yeah time
travel is a really bonkers concept folks
and it tends to Gator really messy all
kinds of directions this could go but as
we look into this more and more deeply
my question for you right now is which
do you think is more likely that Scott
has gone back in time or that Scott
could have phase-shifted into a
different parallel reality where the
Avengers might just not be home comment
down below with your thoughts and hold
on your butt's because we're gonna be
talking about this a lot over the coming
months and again big thanks to our
sponsor Wix Wix allows you to build a
professional website with thousands of
easy-to-use templates that set you up
with the site for whatever you need it
to be look every function an adult needs
a legit place for people to find them
online with a platform that you control
that does what you need it to do whether
it be a blog or a business a place to
show off all your projects in my case
appears back a place to brag about all
the improv teams I was on and big
announcement new rockstars actually used
weeks to build a new website it's live
you can go there right now
thanks to Wix we now have one place
where you have a direct line to us to
give us feedback and help us decide what
kind of videos to make all in a way that
we can really hear it doesn't get buried
and tweets and comment sections when it
comes to design Wix gives you infinite
possibilities to make your website your
own unique masterpiece but as we found
when we made our website Wix takes care
of all the heavy lifting your site will
be safe secure and you do not have to
worry about any weird glitches like if
you tried to build a site alone I've
made that mistake before Wix has a
solution for every need with features
like Wix blog Wix video with stores Wix
booking really anything you need a
website for to improve your life
Wix has you covered so build your own
website today by going to Wix calm / go
/ new rock stars or by using our link in
the description below and follow new
rock stars on Twitter at new rock stars
follow me on Twitter and Instagram a da
boss subscribe to new rock stars for all
the stuff you missed and deeper theories
related to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and Avengers endgame and if you want to
be part of our team you can also support
us on patreon big thanks to Kelly hopper
for all your generosity thanks for
watching and wait a minute what does
that say alright guys 1983 it's the 80s
Lee years oh no I gotta find a stranger
things kids 11 help me or my only on
[Music]